you're so lucky oh just wait you two
meghan trainor has given birth to a baby
boy her first child with hubby daryl
sabara
i'mma cry for sure gonna cry the 28 year
old singer first announced her pregnancy
back in october and
hit it daryl okay
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm just having the best time it's been
so much fun to
watch her grow and um
[Laughter]
following their surprise appearance on
the today show megan posted a sonogram
to instagram writing in the caption you
all know how long i've wanted this
it's so magical it was so hard keeping
this secret forever too
the following week megan opened up to
e.t about the moment she and daryl
learned they were having a boy
i spent so long where i'm like it or
baby
and i didn't know when i could say it
but it's a boy
there's all these myths of like oh if
the heartbeat is really fast it's a girl
and if
your hips are the first to go out it's a
girl and so i was like
it's a girl like i got it i was so
confident
and then when she called us i was like
okay tell us and she's like
what do you think it is my husband's
like a girl and she's like actually
it's a boy daryl when did you know that
megan was
your number one girl day one as soon as
day one oh man i walked in that room
that's what he claims he knows that's
the truth the singer and the 28 year old
spy kids star got engaged in 2017
and they tied the knot in december 2018.
it's all about the perfect timing and
when e.t chatted with the grammy winner
in 2019
she revealed she and daryl were already
talking about starting a family
are you thinking you're thinking about
it though oh every single day of my life
yeah even before we were married i would
cry by while walking by diapers i was
like i should be getting these
yeah and megan told e.t that after
giving birth
she's planning to stay at home for a
while before getting back in the studio
after the album is out and christmas is
there we can just like
focus on like getting ready to give
birth and have a baby and have a human
and then i can just disappear and be mom
are you gonna like take a break like not
recording me i told them
i tell i'm probably not gonna take that
long of a break but i told them
like in my first three months leave me
alone i was like
me baby that's it and husband